finance coming up his best start as a
brewer last time out against minnesota
there's a ground ball over to arcia the
flip for one and the turn and that is a
double play
wow was that pretty 40 or more
strikeouts while allowing less than 10
hits over a four start span in a single
season
bauer corbin johann santana and randy
johnson in 1997 the only four guys to do
it smoke had a good day yesterday he
drove in three
and now the payoff
into center field and that's down to
base hit here comes yalex coming home to
throw from phillip irvin not in time
brewers first on the board
a first inning run for the milwaukee
brewers
on what maybe is a trend busting monday
night well about time i mean the brewers
have been waiting for some early offense
sogard garcia
see you see you later
good morning good afternoon good night
and the 3-2 again
right down the middle heater at 95.
to back punch outs for bauer here in the
second
one two again
swing and a miss
how about bauer in the second
strikes out the side
swing and a miss print them now strength
three as garcia is in the books
and on the back of the mound
as trevor bauer appears to be tipping a
bud
after the strikeout of garcia
raises his hand to his mouth tilts his
head back and underlines the letters
b
u d
s
here a hit by a pitch three and two to
justin smoke
on the move payoff pitch is a drive hit
back in a deep right field castillatos
going back it's gone
two run bomb off the bat of justin smoke
and it's three-nothing brewers in the
third oh look out he's starting to heat
up in a big way oh my goodness that ball
was smoked
halfway up the second deck out there in
right
[Applause]
on a 3-2 pitch
it was a fast ball about belt high
it is count careful on this one
diving stop by farmer pretty play kyle
farmer
just continues to be a ball player
but the brewers get two
narvaez foul down to third base first
time up and he drives under right
drifting back cassiano's it is gone
omar narvaez for the first time as a
brewer goes deep
it's four-nothing milwaukee
bauer with a fastball down the middle
and omar narvaez
hit it out to straight away right field
narvaez with two more hits yesterday to
snap it over 19 and he got on the
fastball here from trevor bauer trying
to put yelich away bauer has five
strikeouts
he's into his wind up he brings it home
breaking ball and a swing gonna miss
down on strikes yelich six strikeouts
for bauer tonight
four nothing and bowers payoff pitch
coming to justin smoke
swing gonna miss struck him out
another breaking ball and bauer is fans
seven tonight we go to the six barnhart
against right-handers casalli against
left-handers and if your start just
happens to fall on one of those days
then that's who you throw to
and casalli hammers this one to deep
left field that's way back there it is
gone into the second deck and left
gert cassalli just unloaded and the reds
are on the board it's now 4-1 milwaukee
fourth home run of the year for the reds
catcher
that ball was destroyed
top of the seventh and the meat of the
order coming up one bull one strike
count here to suarez
and he lifts this one high and deep dead
center field on the run and goodbye
home run off the dead center field wall
by eugenio suarez and it's now a 4-2
ball game
so maybe that phenomenal play at third
got the juices flowing for juan suarez
on the nice play and he crushed that
ball
hit into two double plays earlier and he
lifts this one out of dead center
getting some work here in the seventh
inning two balls two strikes to matt
davidson
and that is strike three called and out
number one yeah right down the middle
change up again
and he wins and that's out number two so
back to back strikeouts out of the
bullpen for devin williams
payoff pitch
change up got him aiming over
devin williams comes out of the bullpen
and strikes out matt davidson mike
mustakas
and philip irvin
[Applause]
has been their best hitter this season
jesse winker
a swing and a miss
and a good start to the eighth inning
for david phelps that one had a lot of
play too and winker swings right through
it
[Applause]
and he wins
later again loads up for the 2-2 pitch
to castellanos
and got him on the slider for out number
one what a pitch here comes a 2-1
bouncing ball arcia uria's game over
as the brewers take the opener of this
four-game series with cincinnati